Hey everybody, how's it going out there? Web 3.0, Breaking Free from the Client Server Model with Michelle Lee. Take it away, Jason. Hey, everybody. How's it going out there? Super, super excited to have Michelle Lee, who's the developer, advocate, and ecosystem growth at Protocol Labs. She is going to tell us all about Web 3.0 and breaking free of this client server model. So, you know, we talked in the past episodes about things like microservices and how to stand up a website and things like that.
大家好，最近怎么样？今天的主题是“Web 3.0：摆脱客户端-服务器模型”，演讲者是米歇尔·李。杰森，请开始吧。大家好，最近怎么样？我们非常非常高兴能邀请到米歇尔·李，她是协议实验室的开发者、倡导者以及生态系统增长负责人。她将为我们详细介绍 Web 3.0 以及如何摆脱这种客户端-服务器模型。所以呢，我们在过去的节目中讨论过诸如微服务、如何搭建网站之类的话题。
But all of these things kind of sit in this central location. And so one of the things that I've always wondered is, you know, what if we all kind of got together? Could we host a website, you know, just, you know, with our community, right? And so it's something I've always been really, really fascinated about. Admittedly, I don't know a lot about it, but we have someone who does know a lot about it. And so thanks so much, Michelle, for coming on the show. Thanks, Jason. Thanks, Patrick. Great to be here. Cool. So before we dive into the topic, why don't you tell us a little bit about, you know, what is your journey that led you to Protocol Labs?
但所有这些东西基本上都集中在一个中心位置。因此，我一直好奇的一件事是，大家有没有想过，如果我们聚在一起会怎么样？我们能不能仅凭我们的社区来托管一个网站？这真的是我一直以来非常非常着迷的事情。诚然，我对它了解不多，但我们今天请到了一位非常精通此道的大咖。非常感谢米歇尔能来到节目中。谢谢杰森，谢谢帕特里克。很高兴来到这里。太好了。那么在我们深入探讨这个话题之前，能先给我们讲讲是什么样的经历让你加入了协议实验室吗？
And what does that story look like? Sure. My background was always at the intersection of technology and people. So I initially wanted to be an architect. And when I took like an architecture 101 course at university, the university lead architect was showing us around some projects. And he's like, well, this project we started 11 years ago, and we're breaking ground now. And me in my short 18 year old life was like, that's two thirds of my lifetime. I can't wait. What can I work on? Like, what kind of my lifetime I can't wait that long what can I work on like what kind of systems can I get involved in creating and designing that are going to happen a
这个故事是怎样的？当然。我的背景一直处于技术与人的交叉点上。我最初的梦想是成为一名建筑师。当我在大学里选修了一门建筑学101课程时，学校的首席建筑师带着我们参观了一些项目。他说：“这个项目啊，我们是11年前开始的，现在才开始动工。”而当时年仅18岁的我觉得，这简直占了我大半生的大部分时间，我等不了。我想参与什么样的工作呢？也就是说，我这一生中，我等不了那么久，我能参与什么样的工作？我能参与创造和设计什么样的系统，才能让进展稍微快一点点？
little bit faster and so I got drawn to like mechanical engineering product design and eventually software design because you can iterate like overnight in your dorm room or you know quickly over the span of a few weeks or months with a small team. So that was what drew me to software in the first place. And then I was always interested in, like, what is causing these bugs that are showing up in my browser or my, you know, at the time it was desktop apps, like what's the logic behind that? And so learning about computer science, eventually learning how memory works, for example, and like why these characters get skipped or what, you know, why bugs or outages happen, drew me further and further into like the design of systems. So I ended up studying human computer interaction, working at Google for quite a while
于是我被机械工程、产品设计以及后来的软件设计所吸引，因为你可以在宿舍里隔夜就完成迭代，或者通过一个小团队在几周或几个月内迅速迭代。这就是最初吸引我进入软件领域的原因。后来我总是对这些问题感兴趣：是什么导致了我的浏览器或——当时还是桌面应用程序中出现的这些bug？背后的逻辑是什么？因此，通过学习计算机科学，最终了解内存是如何工作的，比如为什么这些字符会被跳过，或者为什么bug或宕机会发生，这让我越来越深入地研究系统设计。所以我最后去研究了人机交互，并在谷歌工作了很长时间，
on maps and docs, inventing Google Forms is kind of one of my claims to fame from that time. Wow, really cool. So wait, let's dive into that a bit. So what is human-computer interaction for folks out there? Oh, gosh. It is kind of the amalgamation of cognitive science, so how people perceive language and patterns. Computer science, how software is built and developed. Cognition, what happens in people's brains, interaction design, visual design, really fun interdisciplinary space. Wow, very cool. So would you say the sort of, what's the connection between that and like the user experience?
主要负责地图和文档，发明谷歌表单可以说是我那段时期的代表作之一。哇，太酷了！等等，我们深入聊聊这个。那么对听众来说，什么叫人机交互？天哪。它有点像是认知科学（人们如何感知语言和模式）、计算机科学（软件是如何构建和开发的）、认知学（人们大脑中发生了什么）、交互设计和视觉设计的结合体，是一个非常有趣的跨学科领域。哇，太酷了！那你觉得，这与用户体验之间有什么联系呢？
You know, is that related? Is it about making better user experiences? Absolutely. Yeah. A lot of people who study human-computer interaction go on to work in user experience, user research. I think a layer that's been added on since my time in school is understanding what's the relationship between a focus on maximizing the experience for an individual user and understanding its impact on society. For example, if you try to get me my groceries as fast as humanly possible, or try to
你知道，这有关联吗？它是为了带来更好的用户体验吗？当然。是的。许多研究人机交互的人后来都去从事了用户体验和用户研究工作。在我上学之后，增加的一个新层面是理解：专注于最大化单个用户的体验，与理解这种体验对社会的影响之间，到底是什么关系。举个例子，如果你试图以最快的人类速度把我的杂货送到我手上，或者试图以最快的人类速度把我从A点送到B点，
get me from point A to point B as fast as humanly possible, what are the externalities of that in social networks, social systems, things like that. So yeah, absolutely. It was a really, really fun field to study. Very cool. And so you studied that. And then were you in HCI at Google? What's the connection between that and the Google forum? Yes, I was in HCI at Google? What's the connection between that and the Google Forum? Yes, I was in user experience at Google. Got it. I see. And so actually, oh, Google Forum. Now it's all coming together. So Google Forums is the survey type thing where you can send it out, folks can respond. And then I've actually, to be fair, I've never used it, but I think you get some kind of maybe
在社交网络、社会系统等方面，这会带来什么外部影响？所以，是的，绝对有联系。这是一个非常非常有趣的领域。太酷了。所以你学了这个。然后你当时在谷歌做HCI吗？那和谷歌表单有什么关系？是的，我当时在谷歌做用户体验。明白了。我懂了。其实，哦，谷歌表单。现在一切都串联起来了。所以谷歌表单就是那种调查表，你可以发送出去，然后大家可以填写回复。而且说实话，我其实从来没用过，但我猜它会有一个后台，你能在那里看到所有的回复。
backend where you can see all the responses. Yeah, it's piped in directly to Google Spreadsheets. And I think that's the magic. And that's where it all began because we were having trouble. Users were reporting problems, understanding how the sharing function worked because they were trying to share spreadsheets and get lots of like thousands and thousands of people to contribute data to shared spreadsheets so that people who are managing processes or systems could aggregate all that data and do things with it. Right. And when you hit the
对，它直接连到谷歌电子表格。我觉得这就是它的神奇之处。一切都是从这里开始的，因为当时我们遇到了麻烦。用户反馈说，他们很难理解共享功能是如何工作的，因为他们试图共享电子表格，并让成千上万的人向共享电子表格贡献数据，这样管理流程或系统的人就可以聚合所有这些数据并进行处理。没错。当你点击共享按钮，要求25位急诊室医生填写他们的排班，或者要求500名大学生添加他们的课堂数据时，
sharing button and ask, you know, 25 emergency room doctors to fill in their schedules or 500 university students to add their class data, you end up with editing collisions, people overwrite stuff by accident. And we realized, like, instead of making the share button easier to use, why don't we step back and think, well, only one or two people need to understand the whole data structure behind, you know, in this spreadsheet. Most people are just contributing one row. So we turn it into a form and get input that way, keeps it really clean and lightweight. You don't have to mess around with permissions for the majority of users. And then the people who actually need to manipulate the data once it's in still have the permissions that they need. Wow, that is super cool. And so what was your role there? Were you the one who had
最终就会导致编辑冲突，人们会不小心覆盖彼此的内容。我们意识到，与其让共享按钮变得更好用，不如退一步想想：其实整个电子表格背后庞大的数据结构，只需要一两个搞懂就行了。大多数人其实只是贡献一行数据。所以我们把它做成了一个表单，通过这种方式收集输入，这样既干净又轻量。对于大多数用户来说，你根本不需要去折腾复杂的权限。而那些在数据进入后真正需要操纵数据的人，依然拥有他们所需的权限。哇，这太酷了！那么你在那里的角色是什么？你就是那个灵光乍现的人吗？
the light bulb go off? Yeah, I was the designer sort of beating my head along with some other colleagues. I'm like, how do we make this sharing thing simpler? And then another project I'd worked on, actually my very first project there was getting user feedback for Google checkout transactions, if anyone can remember that, through emails. Yeah. And I think we found like a 70% increase in response rate if you just embed the form elements inside an email, rather than asking people to click on it separately. So we did that as well. We embedded the form for a long time, embedded it inside email, which made things a lot easier for
对，我就是那个和其他同事一起绞尽脑汁的设计师。我在想：“我们怎么才能把共享这件麻烦事变简单呢？”然后我做过的另一个项目，其实我在那里的第一个项目，就是通过电子邮件收集用户对谷歌结账交易的反馈，不知道还有没有人记得这个。是的。然后我想我们发现，如果你直接把表单元素嵌入到电子邮件中，而不是让用户单独点击链接去填写，回复率会提高70%左右。所以我们也这么做了。我们嵌入了这个表单很长一段时间，把它嵌入在邮件里，这给一些人带来了很多便利，
some people, but also was imperfect because email clients all render things a little bit differently. Right, right. Yeah, I've definitely been on the other end of that where I've seen a Google form embedded in email. And sometimes, yeah, there's some wraparound issues and things like that. But to your point, it's so much more convenient. It's amazing, actually, the inertia of a click. You just see study after study after study about, oh, if I have to make one more click, I lose, you know, if my users have to make one more click, I lose, you know, 20% of the users. Like it's unbelievable how important that is. Absolutely. And so we worked with the user researcher, Andrea Knight and developer,
但它也不是完美的，因为不同的邮件客户端渲染网页的方式略有不同。对，对。是的，我也遇到过相反的情况，我见过邮件里嵌入了谷歌表单。有时候，是的，确实会有一些文字排版换行之类的问题。但正如你所说，这确实方便太多了。说实话，点击的惰性真的很惊人。你会看到一项又一项的研究都在说：“哦，如果我让用户多点一下，我就——如果我的用户必须多点一下，我就会流失大约20%的用户。”这简直不可思议，点击率居然这么重要。绝对是这样的。所以我们当时和用户研究员安德烈·奈特以及开发者安迪·邦兹合作开发了第一个原型，安迪现在在Go语言团队工作。
Andy Bonds, who now works on the Go team, to build out the first prototype. And yeah. Cool, cool. So what did you do after Google? After Google, so I started volunteering with a group called NY Cares. And I was living in New York City at the time. And we were helping people with low income file tax returns so that they could gain access to all the tax credits
太棒了。那么你离开谷歌后做了什么？离开谷歌之后，我开始在一个叫“纽约关怀”的组织做志愿者。当时我住在纽约市。我们帮助低收入人群申报纳税申报表，这样他们就能获得公共项目提供的所有税收抵免。
that are available through public programs. And I think we got eight hours of training for it through this, you know, for this tax filing program. And then we were like unleashed into these programs or, you know, once a week for two months before the tax filing deadline, we would help families like compile other paperwork, submit their stuff. And then at, you know, after a 25 or 30 minute appointment, be able to go back to them and say, Hey, you've actually, you're, you're, you're going to get a tax refund of $4,000, which is, I mean, if your household income is $14,000 for a year, that's huge. Right. But these people were, these families were like waiting in line, their kids were napping on the floor, they had to wait a really long time to see us. And at the same time, like, we didn't have any tax expertise, really, we had some light training, and we had some software that we weren't afraid to use. And if you can make that software really accessible to lots of people, make it much more approachable, maybe make it mobile friendly. People could do
为了这个报税项目，我们好像接受了大约八个小时的培训。然后我们就“被放到了”这些项目中，在报税截止日期前的两个月里，每周一次，我们会帮助各个家庭整理他们的其他材料，提交他们的资料。然后在25到30分钟的预约结束后，我们可以告诉他们：“嘿，实际上，你们——你们将获得4000美元的退税。”这——我是说，如果你们一年的家庭收入是14000美元，这可是一大笔钱。没错。但这些人、这些家庭却不得不排着长队等待，他们的孩子在地板上打盹，他们不得不花很长时间来等我们。与此同时，实际上我们并没有什么税务专业知识，我们只接受了一些简单的培训，而且我们有一些不害怕使用的软件。如果你能让这款软件对很多人来说都非常容易使用、非常平易近人，或许还能适配手机端，人们就能在家里完成这些了。
this at home. So I felt it was wonderful, but a little bit pointless for me to be there as the intermediary. And I got interested in how can I work on software that makes government services a lot easier, makes people's lives a lot easier. And I went to South by Southwest in Austin and heard a talk from Jennifer Palka, who was just getting an organization called Code for America off the ground and ended up being so drawn to that that I left my job at Google and went to work at Code for America for a year
所以我觉得这种经历很美妙，但对于我作为中间人坐在那里，其实意义不大。我开始对如何开发让政府服务变得更简单、让人们生活变得更轻松的软件产生兴趣。我去参加了奥斯汀的“西南偏南”大会，听了詹妮弗·帕尔卡的演讲。她当时正在筹建一个名为“为美国而代码”的组织。我被深深地吸引了，以至于我辞去了谷歌的工作，去“为美国而代码”工作了一年，
as a fellow working with local governments to try to make communication and processes more, more human, more easy to use with software. Wow. That is amazing. I, you know, I actually, I've been in Austin for, um, let me see what, maybe two years, almost two years now. And there's never been a South by Southwest because I moved right as the pandemic started. And so I actually haven't, uh, haven't been able to go to South by Southwest because I moved right as the pandemic started. And so I actually haven't been able to go to South by Southwest now that it's right in the backyard, but I'm really looking forward. Do you know if it's coming back this year?
担任了一名研究员，与地方政府合作，试图通过软件让沟通和流程变得更加人性化、更加易于使用。哇。太惊人了。我知道，其实我在奥斯汀待了，让我想想，大概两年，快两年了。而且从来没有办过“西南偏南”大会，因为我搬来的时候正好赶上大流行开始。所以我其实——我其实没去过“西南偏南”，因为我搬来的时候正好赶上大流行开始。所以我其实还没机会去“西南偏南”，尽管它就在我家的后院，但我真的很期待。你知道今年它还会回归吗？
Yes, it is. I think it's a hybrid model and Protocol Ads is actually going to have a big presence there hosting some fun events. So yeah. Oh, very cool. All right. Do you remember, I actually forgot what time of year it is. It's been so long since they did one. It's in March. So it's coming up pretty soon. Oh man. Okay. Very cool. So yeah, when this, when folks get this podcast in their hands, it'll be very close to South by Southwest. Cool. That is awesome. So, okay. So what is Code for America? Oh, you said it was, it was a way to help governments become like a little bit more user, user-friendly. Yeah. Code for America was founded
是的，它会回归。我想它会采用混合模式，而且协议实验室实际上也会在那里大显身手，举办一些有趣的活动。所以，是的。哦，太酷了。好的。你还记得吗？我其实忘了它是一年中的什么时候办的。距离他们上次办已经过去太久了。是在三月份。所以很快就要到了。天哪。好的。太酷了。所以，是的，当大家听到这期播客时，时间应该会非常接近“西南偏南”大会。太棒了。那么，“为美国而代码”到底是什么？哦，你刚才说它是一种帮助政府变得更接地气、对用户更友好的方式。是的。“为美国而代码”的成立
with the mission of bringing modern web technology to, to government. And it's been an amazing organization, had a big influence in shaping some of the programs happening at the federal level as well. The 18F Technology Transformation Service, all those programs kind of are part of the same movement. And speaking of Web 3.0, this is Gov 2.0 was the name given to a lot of these programs. Yeah, and in some cases, it was bringing in amazing tech talent from Silicon Valley. In other cases, it was unleashing and helping break red tape for some of the amazing technologists
使命是将现代网络技术引入政府。这是一个了不起的组织，对塑造联邦层面的某些项目也产生了重大影响。18F技术转型服务，所有这些项目其实都是同一运动的一部分。说到Web 3.0，很多这类项目当时被称为Gov 2.0。是的，在某些情况下，它引入了来自硅谷的顶尖技术人才；而在另一些情况下，它则是为那些已经在政府工作的优秀技术人员释放潜能、打破繁文缛节，但将各方联系起来，并与项目管理联系起来，我认为这对于让人们的生活更轻松而言，是一场非常非常重要的运动。
who are already working for government, but connecting all sides and also connecting to program administration has been, yeah, really, really important movement, I think, in making people's lives easier. Very cool. So when did you start, you know, getting excited about, you know, Web 3.0, about, you know, distributed serving and, you know, Filecoin and IPFS, all these things we're going to
太酷了。那么你是什么时候开始对Web 3.0、分布式服务、Filecoin、IPFS以及所有我们今天要谈论的东西感到兴奋的呢？你是什么时候真正开始涉足这些的？又是什么点燃了你的热情？是的，“为美国而代码”绝大多数的工作和Gov 2.0的工作都是在公开透明的环境下完成的。所以这与过去有了很大的改变。开源软件、模块化组件，对人们完全透明，并且可以在各个州或直辖市之间轻松重用，对吧？开放数据运动也是其中很大的一部分。所以我觉得对我来说，当我开始听到IPFS和开放网络时，这种对互联网创始原则的回归——
talk about. When did you really start getting into that and what sort of sparked that for you? Yeah, the vast majority of Code for America's work and Gov 2.0 work was done in the open. So a big change from the past. Open source software, modular components, very transparent to people and easily reused across states or municipalities, right? And the open data movement was a big part of that as well. So I think for me, when I started hearing about IPFS and the open web, this pull back towards the founding principles of the internet as a you know as an open um and decentralized way to you know connect knowledge and people across multiple destinations i think
作为一个开放且去中心化的方式，在多个目的地之间连接知识和人——我觉得从哲学上讲，这真的非常契合。是的，这非常合乎逻辑。我想，——我的意思是，迈克，你一定听过很多次这种说法，我只是在这里做个类比，但我从很多其他地方听说过：“哦，如果我们只是——”我只是在做个类比，但我从很多其他地方听说过：“哦，如果我们开源，或者如果我们把正在发生的事情告诉别人，那么坏人就会利用我们的成果。”你知道，我觉得这是一个非常有趣的观点，而且其中可能包含了一点真相，但在我看来，另一方面，我觉得这其实是一种对世界的悲观看法。对吧？这种想法认为，如果我把某些东西开源，那么看它的人里面，坏人就会比好人多。我觉得这正是其中的谬误所在。
it was uh philosophically you know really aligned yeah that makes a lot of sense i think that uh i mean you've heard this a lot mike you know i'm just i'm kind of projecting here but i've heard from a lot of other places you know oh if we just, I'm kind of projecting here, but I've heard from a lot of other places, you know, oh, if we, you know, open source, or if we tell people what's going on, then bad people will exploit what we're doing. You know, that's a, I feel like it's a very interesting argument to make, you know, and there might be, there's a nugget of truth there, but I think on the flip side, you know, I feel like it's kind of a pessimistic way of looking at the world, really. Right. This idea that if I put something open source, there's going to be more bad people than good people looking at it. I feel like that's that's kind of the the fallacy there, I think.
所以我觉得看到政府和其他地方转向开源模式，真的是一件很酷的事。这样一来，那些关注它的大多数人其实都是出于善意在看待它。是的。从技术层面上讲，将你的代码放到网络上并为其贴上开源许可证，就是让它开源了。但我认为开源真正的力量在于，当你有多个方对其进行审查、审计、重用，并对其进行类似“实战测试”，然后将这些改进反馈到主代码库中时。这就是开源的力量，它能让事物变得可用、透明，甚至更加安全。
And so I think it's really cool to see, you know, government and and other kind of places, you know, moving to places moving to open source models. And that way, it's like the vast majority of the people who put their eyeballs on that are looking at it in a benevolent way. Yeah. And open source is like, technically speaking, making your code available on the web and putting an open source license on it is making it open source. But I think the real power of open source is when you have multiple parties like reviewing it, auditing it, you know, reusing it and sort of like battle testing it and feeding those
是的，绝对如此。好的，让我们深入探讨一下。我想，从表面上看，Web 3.0到底是什么？是的，我觉得这和刚才你提到的内容有一个很好的过渡，对吧？Web 3.0的构建块之一、也是Web 3.0的原则之一，就是假设你不能信任网上的任何人。你如何利用数学将信任重新带回网络？因此，IPFS（星际文件系统的缩写）有两个基本的构建块。首先，它不用任意的文件名——比如你可能会把这一集命名为 podcast.mp4 或其他什么，但你可能会忘掉，然后把它命名为 podcast5.mp4。
improvements back into the main code base. That is the power of open source to make things, you know, available and transparent and even more secure. Yeah, definitely. Okay, so let's really dive into this. Like, I guess, you know, on the surface, what is Web 3.0? Yeah, I think there's a great transition from what you mentioned, right? Web 3.0, one of the building, like one of the principles of Web 3.0 is assuming that you can't trust anybody on the web. How do you build trust back into the web with math? So IPFS, which stands for interplanetary file system has two basic building blocks. The first is that instead of an arbitrary file name, like you might name this episode podcast.mp4 or whatever, but you might forget and name it podcast5.mp4.
你可能会不小心下载了六个副本，分别命名为 podcast-1、podcast-final 或 podcast-final-final-final。是的，我们确实都干过这种事。相反，IPFS的做法是获取你的数据，并将其通过单向数学函数——也就是哈希函数——进行处理，从而得出一个一致的内容标识符（CID）。所以它基本上是为你的数据创建了一个指纹，而不是让你随意起名字。这意味着它可以保证，当你通过这个指纹请求内容时，你绝对能得到它。这实际上释放了各种不同的网络设计，因为现在既然你能保证得到你要求的数据，你就可以从任何人那里获取它。你可以从街对面的邻居那里获取。你可以通过网络传输数据。因此，这种点对点网络是IPFS背后的另一个重要原则。所以你将这个内容寻址系统与点对点网络结合起来，
You might accidentally download six copies of it and call it podcast-1 or podcast-final or podcast-final-final-final. Yeah, we've definitely done all of that. Instead, what IPFS does is it takes your data and it runs it through um uh one-way mathematical function has passion function and gets um it gets a consistent content id out of it so it basically is creating a fingerprint of your data rather than letting you make arbitrary names and so that means it's guaranteed you know when you ask for content by that fingerprint, you're guaranteed to get it. And that actually frees up all sorts of different network designs, because now if you're guaranteed to get the data you asked for, you can get it from anyone. You can get it from your neighbor down the street. You can get it networking to pass data around the web. So that peer-to-peer networking is the other big principle behind IPFS. So you combine this content addressing system
在全球范围内，任何对等节点（Peer）都可以加入网络，他们可以连接到任何对等节点，找到任意几个节点，然后这些节点反过来又会连接到网络的其余部分。因此，你不是从某个单一的服务器获取数据，而是可以从任何对等节点、或者通过任何连接、通过对等节点的任何路径获取数据。这也让网络变得非常具有韧性。因为如果你还记得的话，偶尔会发生巨大的AWS宕机事故，Slack无法使用，GitHub无法使用，你甚至无法在线支付电费。而在点对点世界里，如果发生这种事，也许你的速度会变慢一点，但内容依然可以通过其他路径找到你。是的。我们深入探讨一下。你在刚才说了非常非常多有趣的内容。我非常喜欢利用数学将信任带回网络的想法。我非常喜欢利用数学将信任带回网络的想法。
with peer-to-peer networking, where any peer across the globe, you know, join a network, they can join any peer, you know, find any few nodes, and then those nodes in turn connect to the rest of the network. And so instead of getting data from any single server, you can get it from any peer or through any connection, any pathway of peers. And that makes the network really resilient as well. Because if you remember, every once in a while, there's a giant AWS outage, Slack doesn't work and GitHub doesn't work and you can't pay your electric bill online. In a peer-to-peer world, if that happens, maybe you have a little slowdown, but the content can find its way to you through other paths. Yeah. Let's dive into that. You said a lot of really, really interesting stuff there. I love the idea of using math to bring trust back into the web. I love the idea of, you know, using math to bring
我觉得这真的太迷人了。这是一个非常基础的理念。很多人会说，甚至哪怕你身处一个社区、一个现实世界的社交社区中，你如何达成共识？很多人都理解对各种议题进行投票之类的做法。所以，你如何达成共识？很多人都理解对各种议题进行投票之类的做法。所以，民主和投票、理性等理念真的很能引起人们的共鸣。然后你可以说，好吧，从表面上看，如果我在互联网上这样做——比如如果我在互联网上发起一个投票，有什么能阻止某人写一个Bash脚本，说：“假设从1到正无穷循环，提交我的投票”？然后那个人拥有的权力就会比其他亲自动手点击的人大得多，对吧？所以，是的，这是一个非常好的观点。
trust back into the web. I think that's really fascinating. This is something that is really foundational. And a lot of folks say, you know, even just if you're in a community, you know, a social community, you know, out in the real world, you know, how do you achieve consensus? And a lot of people understand, you know, kind of voting on issues and all of that. So, you know, how do you achieve consensus? And a lot of people understand, you know, kind of voting on issues and all of that. So, you know, the idea of sort of democracy and voting and, you know, rationality really resonates with people. And then this kind of, but then you can say, well, you know, on the surface level, if I do that on the internet, like if I make a poll on the internet, what's to stop someone from just writing a bash script that says you know four i's one to infinity you know
据我所了解的，基本上数学运算需要计算机付出计算工作，来证明它们在这个投票中投入了成本。所以这种时间成本最终就成了你的某种投资。是这样理解的吗？是的。所以现在在日常用语中很常见的“加密”（Crypto），最初其实是源于密码学（Cryptography），对吧？因此，密码学——也就是支持所有这些玩法的数学——一直以来都是这些系统设计的关键所在。
submit my vote and then that person now has so much more power than someone else who's clicking by hand right and so um so yeah it's a really good point. From what I understand, basically the math operations require computers to do work to prove that they are invested in this vote. And so that time ends up being your sort of investment. Is that kind of a way of saying that? Yeah. And so crypto, which is pretty common in parlance these days, comes from cryptography originally, right? And so the cryptography, the math that enables all this stuff is, you know, continues to be critical to how these systems are designed.
你谈到计算机必须做功。广义上讲，有两类共识系统。一种是工作量证明（Proof of Work），你需要处理器像赛跑一样拼命去做数学运算，以赢得下一个区块的记账权。这就是比特币的设计方式。但当前一代的区块链网络主要采用的是权益证明（Proof of Stake）。也就是说，你对网络贡献了多少？这就是——这就是Filecoin的设计方式。Filecoin网络上的节点根据它们提供多少存储空间、多少有用的存储空间来获得投票权。这种方式更加节能，而且——你知道的，总的来说更有意义，因为我们想要做的是创造潜在价值，对吧？我们不是为了运行CPU而运行CPU，
You talk about, you know, computers having to do work. There's two kinds of consensus systems, broadly speaking. So there's proof of work, which you have processors like racing and racing to do the most math to win the next block. That's how Bitcoin is designed. But the current generation of blockchain networks are primarily proof of stake. So how much are you contributing to the network? that and that's um that's how filecoin is designed so nodes on the filecoin network get votes based on how much storage how much useful storage they provide and this is much more energy efficient and you know just generally makes a lot more sense because what we want to do is like create underlying value right we're not doing math or
我们运行CPU、进行数学运算、进行密码学的目的是为了实现一个完全去中心化且安全的存储系统。明白了。我懂了。所以如果你要做一个类似YouTube的克隆版，那么如果人们创作了很多人都想要的视频，他们就会获得更多的投票权。这里面有很多相似之处，对吧？明白了。好吧。这说得通。太酷了。
running cpus for the sake of running cpus we're we're doing doing math or running CPUs for the sake of running CPUs. We're doing math, doing this cryptography to enable fully decentralized and secure storage system in this case. Got it. I see. So if you're making, let's say, a YouTube clone or something, then people would get more votes if they created videos that a lot of people wanted. There's a lot of parallels, right? Yeah. Got it. Okay. That makes sense. Cool.
所以IPFS就是你计算某个内容的某种哈希和（Hash sum）、SHA和或类似东西的地方。然后这里有一个分布在整个宇宙中的分布式键值存储（Key-Value store），其中键（Key）是SHA哈希，而值（Value）就是内容。所以你可以去查找，说实话这真的让我大开眼界，因为你面临这样一个问题：全世界可能有上百万人拥有同一份内容。
And so IPFS is where you compute some hash sum or some SHA sum or something of a piece of content. And then there's this distributed key value store that's distributed across the whole universe where the key is the SHA and the value is the content. And so you can go and that blows my mind actually because you have this problem of, there might be a million people who have
你必须知道这些人是谁，甚至要知道哪些人离你比较近。这听起来是一个极其困难的问题。是的，我觉得这些Gossipsub协议或去中心化网络的模式，与我们在传统计算机科学课程中学到的一些程序化东西非常不同。我的同事尼古拉·格雷科（Nicola Greco）在几年前的一次团队出游中，给我们做了一个非常有趣的演示。他找了一个房间满是人的屋子，给每个人发了一张写有消息的小纸条，然后说：“嘿，大家就随机交换纸条，直到每个人的纸条上都写着他们自己的名字。”结果这个过程进行得极快。我认为这就是能够并行化所有路由和搜索带来的好处。
that piece of content all over the world. And you have to kind of know who those people are, and even know, you know, which ones are close to you. Seems like a phenomenally difficult problem. Yeah, I think this, these patterns of gossip sub or like decentralized networking are really, really different than some of the procedural stuff we're taught in traditional computer science classes. One of my colleagues, Nicola Greco, did a really fun demo with us at a team offsite a bunch of years ago. He had a room full of people, gave every one of them a little piece of paper with a message and said, hey, just like randomly swap messages until everyone has the piece of paper with their name on it. And it happened so quickly. I think that's the benefit of being able to parallelize all the routing and search. And it
它比我们把所有人排成一队，然后试着通过二分排序或其他更线性的方式来组织和排序人们要快得多。是的，这说得通。是的。我的意思是，在数学中，我们有一个概念叫作模拟退火（Simulated annealing）。基本上，你对某个东西做一些小的改动。如果改动后变好了，你就保留它；如果没变好、反而变差了，那么你有一定的概率依然保留它。然后你慢慢降低这个概率，直到你只保留那些变得更好的改动。这就是退火的部分。而且它的效果好得惊人。
was a lot faster than it would have been if we'd like lined everyone up and tried to, you know, organize and sort people through binary sort or something more linear. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah. I mean, in math, we have this concept called simulated annealing, where basically you make small changes to something. And if the change is better, you keep it. And if it's not better, if it's worse, then there's a percent chance you keep it. And you slowly decrease that percent chance until you're only keeping things that are better. That's the annealing part. And it works amazingly well. and the Python graph library, and you try and do some NP-complete problems,
如果你使用Python的图形库，并尝试去解决一些NP完全问题——比如尝试解决旅行商问题或诸如此类的问题，他们通常就会使用基于模拟退火的近似算法。所以它极其强大，但又非常简单。而且我觉得正如你所说，它利用了这样一点：当你加入混乱时，只要你能进行测量，那么加入大量的混乱实际上会产生非常好的效果。就像在你的例子中，如果你还记得的话，测量的标准就是——
like you try and do traveling salesmen or one of these things, they'll have an approximation that uses simulated annealing. So it's extremely powerful, but very simple. And I think to your point, it's taking advantage of just, when you add chaos, as long as you can measure, then adding a lot of chaos actually works really well. Like in your case, the measurement is, if I remember correctly,
一旦你拿到了写着你名字的纸条，你就完成了。所以你拥有了这样一种系统变好了的衡量标准。一旦你能做到这一点，那么即使做了一大堆混乱的事情，结果也依然会非常好。不过，说到比较实际的部分，我以前做过很多网络方面的工作，那真是太痛苦了。人们有各种网络地址转换（NAT）层。有些人处在对称型NAT后面。所以他们做不了什么事。他们只能读取，无法提供任何服务。你知道，有时候——你会遇到网络上各种各样奇怪的情况。那么像IPFS是如何处理互联网的？这到底有多复杂？
you know, if you have, once you have the piece of paper with your name on it, then you're done. So you have that sort of measure of, you know, the system is better now. And once you can do that, then yeah, even doing a whole bunch of chaotic things ends up working really well. So, but getting down to like the practical part of it, you know, I've done a lot with networking and it's rough. I mean, people have these network translation layers. Some people are behind symmetric NATs. And so they can't do much of anything. They can only read. They can't serve anything. You know, other times it's like you have, you know have kind of all sorts of weird situations on the network. And so how does something like IPFS handle the web and how complicated?
我的意思是，我们现在还没普及IPv6呢。所以，IPFS处理这些问题一定需要极其庞大的逻辑量。你究竟该如何测试这样的东西呢？你必须务实，并意识到大多数人仍然是通过Web 2.0访问互联网的，但我们希望走向一个不再需要Web 2.0的世界。所以今天，当你把内容放到IPFS网络上时，如果你是通过一个IPFS节点来访问这个IPFS网络——例如，你为Chrome下载了IPFS桌面扩展程序，或者你正在运行一个节点并通过命令行与它交互。如果你真的在自己的电脑上运行了一个节点（这非常容易且快速就能搞定），你就可以通过我们刚才谈到的分布式哈希表（DHT），直接从IPFS网获取数据。
I mean, we're not on IPv6 yet. So I mean, how does IPFS, it must be just an insane amount of logic to handle that. And how do you even test something like that, right? You have to be pragmatic and realize the majority of people still access the web through web 2.0, but we want to move to, to a world where that's not required. So today, when you put content onto the IPFS network, if you're accessing the, that IPFS network through, through an IPFS node, for example, you download IPFS desktop extension for Chrome, or you're running a node and interacting with it through the command line. If you actually have a node on your computer, which is really easy and fast to get set up, you can get data directly
但在很多情况下，IPFS是Web应用程序的一部分，或者你想获取它。而那些没有安装这些东西的人，则希望通过更标准的网页浏览器来获取它。在这种情况下，流量会通过各种网关进行路由。因此，网关有点像Web2和Web3之间的翻译官。有一些IPFS节点会说：“嘿，我既懂Web2又懂Web3。我懂HTTP和IPFS。所以你可以向我索取任何内容标识符（CID），把它附加到诸如gateway.ipfs.io这样的地址后面——Cloudflare也运营着一个非常棒、非常高效的网关，”
from the IPFS network through this distributed hash table that we just spoke of. But in a lot of cases, IPFS is part of a web application or you want to fetch it. And someone who doesn't have those things installed wants to fetch it through a more standard web browser. And in that case, the traffic is routed through any number of gateways. So gateways are sort of like translators between Web2 and Web3. There are IPFS nodes that say, hey, I speak both Web2 and Web3. I speak HTTP and IPFS. So you can ask me for any content ID, append it to like gateway.ipfs.io or Cloudflare runs a really awesome, really efficient gateway as well.
它们会在HTTP请求和IPFS网络之间传递数据。所以你可以通过任何东西访问它。我们正在做的另一项重大举措，是与浏览器进行伙伴合作和协作，包括当今的一些主流浏览器，以及未来一些新兴的、非常有趣的浏览器，将IPFS支持直接构建到浏览器中。因此，你的网页浏览器可能能够从HTTP请求数据，但它同时也能够原生支持IPFS。哇，这太酷了！
And they'll pass the data between HTTP requests and the IPFS network. So you can access it through anything. The other big initiative we're doing is we're partnering and collaborating with browsers, both like some of the big browsers of today and also some of the emerging, really interesting browsers of tomorrow, to build IPFS support directly into the browser. And so your web browser might be able to request data from HTTP, but it would also be able to speak IPFS support directly into the browser. And so your web browser might be able to request data from HTTP, but it would also be able to speak IPFS natively. Wow, that is so cool.
你能给我举个例子，说明什么是未来的浏览器吗？我也想要一个。嗯，Brave浏览器绝对是值得关注的一个。而且Brave支持很多去中心化的……哦，好吧！我们之前已经宣传过它了。我们非常喜欢Brave。太酷了。
Can you give me an example of what's a browser of tomorrow? I want one of these. Well, Brave browser is definitely one to look at. And Brave supports a bunch of decentralized. Oh, okay. We've already promoted those. We love Brave. Very cool.
所以Brave浏览器现在已经或者在某个时候将拥有IPFS支持？它原生支持IPFS。我想你可能需要手动启用它，但它确实内置了IPFS支持。哦，我明白了。所以里面有一个设置，你把它打开，
So Brave either does or at some point it will have IPFS support? Has native IPFS support. I think you have to enable it, but it has IPFS support. Oh, I see. So there's a setting, you toggle that on
然后你说——我猜有一个IPFS协议，你可以在里面传入哈希值？对。所以你不用http，而是直接输入 ipfs:// 这样的格式，它就知道该如何获取这些数据了。那关于——你知道，哈希值都是这种超长的字符串，真的很难记住，这上面是不是有什么类似DNS的东西？哦，有的。比如ENS、HNS，也就是以太坊命名服务（Ethereum naming service）、
and then you say, I guess there's an IPFS protocol where you pass in the hash? Yeah. So instead of http just put ipfs colon forward slash forward slash and it will know how to to get that data what about like you know hashes are these you know super long strings that are you know really difficult to remember is there like a dns on top of this or something? Oh, yeah. There's ENS, there's HNS, Ethereum naming service,
握手命名服务（Handshake naming service）。有几种命名服务试图提供更具人类可读性的名字和地址，你可以把它们当作IPFS CID的某种代理来使用。太酷了。那么，你如何防止某些人凭空创造大量内容，然后用海量的随机、虚假或垃圾内容来淹没哈希表呢？
Handshake naming service. There are a few naming services that try to put more human legible names, addresses that you can use as sort of proxies for your IPFS CID. Very cool. And so how do you keep somebody from just, you know, creating a ton of content and just flooding the hash table, which is tons and tons of random or bogus or, you know, content? IPFS has some built-in garbage collection. So if data that's less requested over time, the node will just start dropping it when it exceeds its memory allocation. And so if you want to ensure that the data sticks around, you can run a bunch of nodes and pin it yourself, or you can ask a pinning service,
IPFS内置了一些垃圾回收机制。因此，如果随着时间的推移，某些数据的请求量变少，当超出其内存分配时，节点就会开始丢弃这些数据。所以如果你想确保数据能够长期保留，你可以运行一堆节点并自己进行“固定”（Pin），或者你可以找一个托管服务提供商（有点类似于托管服务商）来帮你保留，或者你也可以在Filecoin网络上签订存储交易，以保持它采用相同的原生IPFS格式。啊，我明白了。这说得通。
which is kind of like a hosting provider to keep it around, or you can make storage deals on the Filecoin network to keep it around in that same native IPFS format. Ah, I got it. That makes sense. It's kind of like, it's somewhat a parallel to advertising. Like there are some nodes that are kind of influencers and you would ask those folks to kind of pin your content, and that kind of keeps
这有点类似于——它在某种程度上类似于广告。就像有些节点有点像网红，你会请那些人来帮你的内容“加精/固定”，这样就能保持它的热度。我想这就是它的设计初衷，对吧？然后如果你想确保万无一失，你可以采取其他步骤。但就用数据淹没网络的情况而言，举个例子，正因为它是如此去中心化，正因为有这么多的节点，所以要想强迫整个网络都来固定你的数据是非常困难的。没错，这说得通。
it relevant. I think that's the design, right? And then if you want to ensure it, you can take other steps. But in terms of data flooding the network, for example, again, it's that because it's so decentralized, because there are so many nodes, it's difficult to force the entire network to pin your data. Right, right. That makes sense. Okay, so what is the difference between IPFS and Filecoin? Great question. A lot of people want to know that. So IPFS and Filecoin both share this IPFS-based content addressing system. Now, IPFS pinning or storage is fully voluntary on the part of the nodes. There's no, because it's peer-to-peer, there's no centralized entity.
好的，那么IPFS和Filecoin之间有什么区别？问得好。很多人都想知道这个。所以，IPFS和Filecoin都共享这个基于IPFS的内容寻址系统。现在，IPFS的固定或存储完全是节点自愿行为。由于它是点对点（P2P）的，因此没有中心化的实体，没有任何东西可以保证这些数据一定会留存下来。所以如果你让我去固定某个东西，但我内存用完了，我可以说：“哦，抱歉，我得把它删了。”
There's no way to guarantee that that data is going to stick around. So if you ask me to pin something, but I run out of memory, I can go, oh, sorry, I got to drop it. Now, if you want to ensure that you can pay a pinning service provider, but if you don't want to pay any single company, if you want to make sure it happens like fully transparently in a decentralized way, then we can make a storage deal. You can say, hey, I'll pay you this amount if you keep my data around for this amount of time, we'll put it on the blockchain. And I, as the provider, will put down some collateral. And then the chain, the mechanisms of the chain will ask me every 24 hours, hey,
现在，如果你想确保数据万无一失，你可以付费请一个固定服务提供商；但如果你不想付钱给任何单一公司，如果你想确保这一切完全透明、以去中心化的方式发生，那么我们可以进行一笔存储交易。你可以说：“嘿，如果你能把我的数据保留这段时间，我愿意付给你这么多钱，我们把这个交易放到区块链上。”而我作为提供商，会质押一些抵押品。然后链上的机制会每隔24小时问我一次：“嘿，你还保存着那个数据吗？向我证明一下。”如果我在任何一次证明中失败了，我就会受到惩罚。所以整个交互交易和执行都是通过区块链网络来完成的。
do you still have that data? Prove it to me. And if I fail any of those proofs, I'll get penalized. So the whole interaction deal and enforcement happens through the blockchain network. Wow, that is super cool. There was a time when I was really deep diving into auctions and I was studying commodity auctions, where in other words, a farmer is raising cattle and it takes so many years to raise the cattle. And so the farmer needs some stability. And so there's this whole like futures market where, and people who like Patrick, who are really into the stock market are probably just laughing at me. So I'm going to, I'm going to give a really dumb person's overview of this, but you know, you set up a
哇，这太酷了。曾经有一段时间我深入研究过拍卖，我研究的是商品拍卖。换句话说，一个农民在养牛，养牛需要好几年的时间。所以这个农民需要某种稳定性。于是就有了整个期货市场——而像帕特里克这样对股市非常痴迷的人现在可能正在嘲笑我。所以我打算——我打算用一个笨蛋的视角来概述这一点，但是，你知道的，你建立了一份合同，上面写着：“我将在18个月后交付这些小麦。”然后，你知道的，如果发生了一场大暴风雨之类的意外，你就必须设法从别的地方弄到小麦来履行这份合同，否则你就要支付一大笔违约金。
contract saying, you know, I will deliver, you know, this wheat in 18 months. And then, you know, if there's a big storm or something, then you have to try to get the wheat from somewhere else to try to fulfill that contract or you pay, you know, kind of a big penalty. You know, and so these sort of features and derivatives are really how things, you know, become more stable. And so it sounds kind of like that for this. So you, you know, you want a group of people, let's say you, let's say you, to make it concrete, you have a backup. We have a backup of the programming throw down, you know, source files, like the raw audio files. We want to save those in case their house is burned down or something. So we put it on, on Filecoin and a few folks agree to host this, this like, you know, encrypted zip file or something for us. And so then they put some collateral
你知道，所以这些期货和衍生品正是事物变得更加稳定的方式。所以这听起来有点像这个项目的运作方式。所以，你——你想让一群人——假设你——为了把它具象化，我们有一个备份，比如我们把《Programming Throwdown》节目的源代码、原始音频文件做个备份。我们想把它们保存起来，以防他们的房子被烧毁什么的。所以我们把它放在Filecoin上，然后一些人同意为我们托管这个——比如加密的压缩文件之类的数据。所以他们会质押一些抵押品
and every now and then Filecoin will say, hey, give us a hash of this part of that file. And if they lost the file, they can't do that. And so the idea is because they've put that collateral on the line and you've replicated this to enough folks, you can be pretty guaranteed someone's going to hold on to it. Exactly. Yeah. And this is now, we're over 14 exabytes of storage. So there's a bunch of storage. This is still a tiny fraction of the world's storage, but it's by far the largest decentralized storage network in the world. Wow. that is really, really cool.
每隔一段时间，Filecoin 就会说，嘿，给我们这个文件某一部分的哈希值。如果他们把文件弄丢了，就做不到这一点。所以其理念是，既然他们已经质押了抵押品，而且你也将文件复制给了足够多的节点，你就可以有相当大的把握确信总有人会妥善保存它。完全正确。是的。而且现在，我们的存储量已经超过了 14 EB。所以这上面有很多存储空间。这仍然只占全球存储空间的一小部分，但它迄今为止是全球最大的去中心化存储网络。哇，这真的很酷。
So I'm trying to wrap my head around this. So what's the connection? When you were talking about the browser and IPFS, could someone actually make a website where all the assets are coming from IPFS? Or would someone just be waiting forever for that to load? No, you can do that really easily. You can actually make a fully decentralized web app.
所以我正在努力理解这一点。那么这之间的联系是什么？当你谈到浏览器和 IPFS 时，有没有人真的可以做一个所有资产都来自 IPFS 的网站？还是说用户得等上个半天才能加载出来？不，你可以非常轻松地做到这一点。你实际上可以制作一个完全去中心化的网络应用。
So at the front end application layer, you can store those assets on IPFS. And there are gateways that will serve that content to you. Fleek is a really great way. It's kind of like Netlify, but for Web3. You can connect it to any GitHub repo that has your web application and it will automatically deploy it to IPFS. So super, super simple. You actually don't really need to understand IPFS even to get it up and running. And then behind the scenes, you can use smart contract logic or standard application logic or combination, most likely, for your logic layer. And then behind the scenes, that data can be stored.
因此在前端应用层，你可以将这些资产存储在 IPFS 上。并且有网关会为你提供这些内容。Fleek 是一种非常棒的方法。它有点像 Netlify，但它是为 Web3 设计的。你可以将它连接到任何包含你网络应用的 GitHub 仓库，它就会自动将其部署到 IPFS。所以超级超级简单。实际上，你甚至不需要了解 IPFS 就能让它上线运行。而在幕后，你可以使用智能合约逻辑、标准应用逻辑，或者最可能是两者的组合来作为你的逻辑层。然后在这背后，数据就可以被存储起来。
We have a layer of tooling called data brokers that deal with all the IPFS and Filecoin nodes for you. And then under the hood, it's stored on these decentralized networks. So you can, I think Uniswap actually is a fully decentralized web application. The front end is, serves your IPFS, the backend and the transactions are pushed to blockchain. So there's no single database for it. Got it. And so I have this, like, albeit kind of pessimistic kind of vision where, you know, you go to a website and, in practice, what's the latency like if you want to look up? I mean, I'm sure it depends on how popular your site is, but for let's say a site that maybe you didn't just put it up now, but it's also, you know, not super popular. What would that sort of latency look like? Would that be usable? And so that's why we strongly recommend using one of the data brokers or pinning service
我们有一层名为数据代理（data brokers）的工具，它们会为你处理所有的 IPFS 和 Filecoin 节点。然后在底层，数据被存储在这些去中心化的网络中。所以你可以——我认为 Uniswap 实际上就是一个完全去中心化的网络应用。前端是由 IPFS 提供服务的，后端和交易则被推送到区块链上。因此它没有单一的数据库。明白了。所以我有这样一种——虽说有点悲观的远景，你知道的，当你访问一个网站时，实际上，如果你想进行查询，延迟会是怎样的？我的意思是，我确信这取决于你的网站有多受欢迎，但假设对于这样一个网站，可能你不是刚刚才把它搭建好，但它也（你知道的）不是超级受欢迎。那种延迟会是什么样的？这会是可用的吗？所以这就是为什么我们强烈建议使用其中一个数据代理或固定服务
providers if you want to serve any production application over IPFS. Makes sense. So Pinata and Fura are a couple of those pinning service providers. And then there are data brokers like NFT Storage, Web3 Storage, which we can talk about in a moment, and Estuary, which do the kind of the hard work of getting that data propagated across multiple nodes, IPFS and FilePoint nodes across the network. Yeah, I mean, seems like a good time to dive into that. What is a data broker? Today's sponsor is Rollbar. Rollbar is the leading platform that enables developers to
提供商，如果你想通过 IPFS 提供任何生产级应用的话。有道理。所以 Pinata 和 Infura 就是几个这样的固定服务提供商。然后还有像 NFT Storage、Web3 Storage 这样的大数据代理——我们一会儿可以聊聊它们——以及 Estuary，它们负责完成艰巨的工作，让数据在整个网络的多个节点、IPFS 和 Filecoin 节点之间进行传播。是的，我的意思是，现在似乎是深入探讨这个好时机。什么是数据代理？今天的赞助商是 Rollbar。Rollbar 是领先的平台，能够让开发者
proactively discover and resolve issues in their code, allowing them to work on continuous code improvement throughout the software development lifecycle. Rollbar has plans for all situations, from free to large enterprise. With Rollbar, developers deploy better software faster and can quickly recover from critical errors as they happen. We have a special URL at There you can find two free ebooks, How Debugging is Changing and How Dev Experience Matters, as well as sign up for a free trial of Robar. What is a data broker?
在其代码中主动发现并解决问题，让他们在整个软件开发生命周期中致力于持续改进代码。Rollbar 针对各种情况都制定了方案，从免费版到大型企业版都有。借助 Rollbar，开发者可以更快地部署更好的软件，并能从发生的严重错误中迅速恢复。我们在 网址提供了一个特殊的 URL，在那里你可以找到两本免费电子书：《调试是如何改变的》以及《开发者体验为什么重要》，还可以注册试用 Rollbar。什么是数据代理？
Yeah, so it's really funny. If you take the name Protocol Labs and the first part protocols, for a long time, we were really focused on the R&D, R-D&D research development deployment of the protocols themselves. So some of the underlying pieces of IPFS, for example, libp2p, which is the peer-to-peer networking protocol, IPFS, IPLD, which is like the data library underneath. These were all where we put the vast majority of our time and attention. But to get developers to use this stuff easily, we kind of needed to stitch them together into tooling and really simple performance APIs. So there's now a layer of tools built through collaborations with other parties across the open source community.
对，所以这真的很有趣。如果你拿协议实验室（Protocol Labs）这个名字来看，前半部分是“协议（protocols）”，在很长一段时间里，我们真的专注于 R&D（研发），也就是协议本身的研发和部署。因此，举例来说，IPFS 的某些底层组件，比如 libp2p——这是点对点网络协议，还有 IPFS、IPLD——这就像底层的数据库。这些是我们投入绝大部分时间和精力的地方。但为了让开发者能够轻松使用这些东西，我们某种程度上需要将它们组合成工具以及非常简单的性能 API。因此，现在通过与开源社区中其他各方的合作，已经构建起了一层工具。
Some of them come from internal protocol labs teams, but there's now a whole rainbow of options for storing your data to make storing your data super, super easy. And NFT.storage provides free storage forever for NFTs specifically. If you submit your NFT, you get back nicely formatted metadata that can be used in a smart contract to compose your token. Web3.storage is a very, very similar service, uses a lot of the same backend, but you Estuary, which is a similar service, but really optimized for performance. And then there's a few other services, ChainSafe, Fleek, Textile have all created other services that act as data brokers. So they basically take all the pinning interactions, all the deal making that would happen on chain, and they swish it into a single API call and let you just call that and forget about the rest.
其中一些来自协议实验室的内部团队，但现在存储数据有了一整套丰富多彩的选择，能让存储数据变得超级超级简单。NFT.storage 为 NFT 专门提供永久免费的存储服务。如果你提交你的 NFT，你就会拿回格式良好的元数据，这些元数据可以用在智能合约中来组合你的代币。Web3.storage 是一个非常非常相似的服务，使用了许多相同的后端，但你可以... Estuary，这是一个相似的服务，但真正针对性能进行了优化。此外还有一些其他服务，ChainSafe、Fleek、Textile 都创建了作为数据代理的其他服务。所以它们基本上把所有的固定交互、所有原本会在链上进行的交易撮合，都压缩成了一个单独的 API 调用，让你只需调用它，然后把剩下的事忘掉就行了。
Got it. I see. And so, you know, one of the things that, so there's two things that, that, you know, frustrate or scare or, you know, intimidate a lot of people about client server, right? One is the fear that, you know, if my website makes it on Hacker News, that my server will blow up, right? And then the second fear is, you know, I put my server as a, you know, Kubernetes auto scaling group. And so now my website made on Hacker News and I have like an $80,000 bill from Amazon. And so I think IPFS and these technologies, the thing that I think is really awesome about them is that as things get more popular, they also get easier to access. And so what does that look like? Let's say I have a data broker who I'm paying,
明白了。我懂了。所以，你知道，其中一件事——所以有两件事，（你知道的）让许多人对客户端-服务器感到沮丧、害怕或者说畏惧，对吧？一个是担心（你知道的）如果我的网站登上了 Hacker News，我的服务器就会崩溃，对吧？然后第二个恐惧是，（你知道的）我把我的服务器设为（你知道的）Kubernetes 自动扩展组。所以现在我的网站上了 Hacker News，我收到了亚马逊发来的 8 万美元账单。所以我想 IPFS 和这些技术，我认为它们真正棒的地方在于，随着事情变得越来越受欢迎，它们也变得更易于访问了。那么这会是什么样的呢？假设我有一个数据代理，我正在向其付费，
I assume regularly to keep this content alive. And then all of a sudden, you know, I make number one on Hacker News and my site blows up, then, you know, in a sense that kind of makes the data broker's job kind of easier, I guess, because you don't have to worry about pinning. And so how does that affect the cost? And, you know And just that problem, those problems I talked about, what happens to them in Web 3.0? So our approach is that the majority of the network consumption storage usage is by very, very large, large scale data users. And so for services like NFT.storage, Web3.storage, that's all provided for free. So most individual application developers or even smaller companies can do this all for free. And so you're not going to be hit by these surprise bills. And exactly like you said,
我假设是定期付费以保持这个内容存活。然后突然之间，（你知道的）我登上了 Hacker News 的头条，我的网站崩溃了，那么（你知道的）在某种意义上，这倒有点让数据代理的工作变得更容易了，我猜，因为你不需要担心固定（pinning）了。那么这会如何影响成本呢？还有（你知道的）仅仅是那个问题，我谈到的那些问题，它们在 Web 3.0 中会变成什么样？所以我们的方法是，网络消耗和存储使用的大头是由非常非常大型、大规模的数据用户产生的。因此，对于像 NFT.storage、Web3.storage 这样的服务，这些全都是免费提供的。所以大多数个人应用开发人员甚至小型公司都可以完全免费地使用这些。因此，你不会遭遇这些突如其来的账单袭击。而且就像你刚才说的，
the more popular something becomes, the more copies there are across the globe. And so the cost to actually get it to an incremental new user is going to be a lot less than having to repeatedly go back to the same server. Got it. So for folks who are bigger, what does the pricing model look like? I'm assuming, I guess it's like at some point you're paying for requests, but then at some point, you get this law of marginality, right? Because as things get more popular, the requests get cheaper. How does that work? If you go to the website file.app, So F-I-L-E dot A-P-P. There's some cost comparisons to AWS. And right now, the cost to store is about 1% of 1%, the cost of Amazon S3. Wow.
某样东西变得越受欢迎，全球各地的副本就越多。因此，将其传给一个新增用户的实际成本，要比不得不反复访问同一台服务器低得多。明白了。那么对于规模更大的用户群体，定价模式是什么样的？我猜，我猜测就像是在某个时刻你为请求付费，但随后在某个时刻，你会获得这种边际效益递减规律，对吧？因为随着事情变得越来越受欢迎，请求变得更便宜了。那是怎么运作的？如果你访问网址 file.app，就是 F-I-L-E 点 A-P-P。那里有一些与 AWS 的成本对比。目前，存储成本大约是 Amazon S3 成本的万分之一。哇。
Wow. That is wild. Super, super cool. I remember this is like seven or eight years ago, I was looking into this kind of stuff and there was something called Peernet and it was this Java application you would run and it was really clunky. I mean, I was able to get it to work, but I mean, trying to get my parents or something on Peernet would have been really, really hard. And it's amazing to see, to see, you know, kind of where, how far things have come and how easy they are. And this is, this is really, really exciting.
哇。太疯狂了。超级超级酷。我记得大概是七八年前，我正在研究这类东西，当时有个东西叫 Peernet，那是一个你可以运行的 Java 应用，而且非常笨重。我的意思是，我能让它运行起来，但是，想让我父母或什么人去用 Peernet 会非常非常难。看到（看到，你知道的）事情发展到了今天这一步，取得了多大的进展，而且变得如此简单，这真是太令人惊叹了。这真是——真的非常令人兴奋。
So, so any folks out there, actually we, we had Guillermo Rauch on the show to talk about Next.js, which is by Vercel, which is a similar setup as Netlify, where you can do like a next push on the command line and your app gets kind of pushed to the web. And so there's, you know, folks have listened to that and have tried building a sample app. Or if you've used Netlify directly and built an app there, you know how easy that is to get your app out there. And so it sounds like, you know, they've made it that easy for Web 3.0. You can push an app pretty easily and you can access it. Do you know if like when Brave will kind of open that up to everybody or how long it's going to be kind of buried in the settings? Yeah. So as you
所以，所以外面的任何人，事实上我们——我们在节目中请来了 Guillermo Rauch 来谈论 Next.js，这是 Vercel 推出的，类似于 Netlify 的设置，你可以在命令行中做一个 next push，然后你的应用就会被推送到网络上。所以，有（你知道的）人们听了那个节目并且尝试构建了一个示例应用。或者如果你直接使用过 Netlify 并在那里构建过应用，你就知道让你的应用上线是多么容易。所以听起来，（你知道的）他们已经为 Web 3.0 做到如此简单了。你可以相当轻松地推送一个应用并且访问它。你知道 Brave 什么时候会向所有人开放这个功能，或者它还要在设置里隐藏多久吗？是的。所以正如你
said, as you mentioned, it's now super easy for developers to get their apps published on IPFS. And then you mentioned the situation of like, Hey, getting your parents to use decentralized storage space. So the fleet team has a product called space.storage and it behaves a lot like Dropbox. So you don't have to be a developer to use it. Oh, super cool. Yeah. And that behind the scenes stores on IPFS and FilePoint. So if you're just a personal user, I don't recommend trying to do things on the command
所说，正如你所提到的，现在开发者可以超级轻松地将他们的应用发布到 IPFS 上了。然后你提到了这样的情况，比如，嘿，让你的父母去使用去中心化的存储空间。因此 Fleek 团队有一个名为 space.storage 的产品，它的行为非常像 Dropbox。所以你不必成为一个开发者也能使用它。哦，超级酷。是的，而这在幕后是将数据存储在 IPFS 和 Filecoin 上的。所以如果你只是一个个人用户，我不建议尝试在命令行上进行操作
line unless you really enjoy that. If you just want something easy and drag and drop, familiar to most computer users, space.storage is that to try. Very cool. Okay. So let's talk about some of the, you know, a little bit less exciting, but still super important kind of questions. Two that come to mind are, you know, how do I protect, like privacy? If I want to put a document in Dropbox, how do I make sure no one else can read my documents? And then other than privacy, you know, how do you deal with bad content on IPFS? I'm sure you get these two questions a lot. Yeah, absolutely. I just want to wrap up. I think I didn't quite answer your prior question, which is when is IPFS support going to be available to everyone in Brave? It's available to everyone right now.
除非你真的很享受那个过程。如果你只是想要一些简单、拖放式、对大多数电脑用户来说很熟悉的东西，space.storage 就是用来尝试的。非常酷。好的。那我们来谈谈其中一些（你知道的）稍微没那么令人兴奋、但依然超级重要的问题。浮现在脑海中的有两个问题，（你知道的）我该如何保护隐私？如果我想把一份文档放进 Dropbox，我如何确保没有其他人能阅读我的文档？然后除了隐私之外，（你知道的）你如何处理 IPFS 上的不良内容？我确信你经常遇到这两个问题。是的，绝对的。我只是想总结一下。我觉得我刚才没有完全回答你的前一个问题，那就是 IPFS 的支持什么时候会对 Brave 中的所有人开放？它现在对所有人开放了。
You just have to go into settings and click enable IPFS. Okay, cool. Yeah. That basically just starts an IPFS node on your computer while you're using Brave and uses that to talk to the IPFS network natively. that make you part of that distributed hash table? Like, can you, there's got to be a way where you can maybe say, you know, don't use all of my bandwidth or, you know, you can mute it for a little bit if you have a video call or something. Yeah, yeah, definitely. There is, I think the IPFS component is configured to run garbage collection once the cache reaches one gigabyte. So it's not going to consume your whole, you know, using it through Brave is not going to consume all of your resources.
你只需要进入设置并点击启用 IPFS。哦，酷。是的。这基本上只是在你使用 Brave 的同时在你的计算机上启动了一个 IPFS 节点，并利用它以原生方式与 IPFS 网络进行通信。这会让你成为分布式哈希表的一部分吗？就像，总得有个方法你可以（比如）说，（你知道的）不要占用我全部的带宽，或者（你知道的）如果你在进行视频通话或类似的事情时，你可以将它静音一会儿吧？是的，是的，绝对可以。有一个，我认为 IPFS 组件被配置为当缓存达到 1 GB 时运行垃圾回收。所以它不会耗尽你的全部——（你知道的）通过 Brave 使用它不会耗尽你的所有资源。
If you want to run it, if you want to run a network or a node, sorry, that, you know, is incredibly generous, you can configure that node to do so. But by default, it doesn't beat all of your resources. That makes sense. Oh, yeah. I was saying, how do you have privacy
如果你想运行它，如果你想运行一个网络或者一个节点，抱歉，这个节点（你知道的）极其慷慨，你可以将该节点配置为这样做。但默认情况下，它不会用尽你的所有资源。这就说得通了。哦，是的。我刚才在说，你如何在 IPFS 上拥有隐私
on IPFS? So if I use Dropbox, I can put some form that I've signed in Dropbox and I'm pretty confident no one else will be able to read it. How can I get that same kind of situation with IPFS? Yeah. So we try to use the same exact parallels. So the space application is encrypted by default. The ChainSafe application is encrypted by default. So web-based end-user applications often have encryption built in. So they'll encrypt the data before it puts it on the network. And then in an application design setting, you'd want to do the same thing. It's just like using AWS, for example. If you want to keep that data private, you would encrypt it using state-of-the-art encryption algorithms and then put it on the network.
呢？所以如果我使用 Dropbox，我可以在 Dropbox 中放入一些我签署过的表格，而且我非常有信心没有其他人能够阅读它。我如何能在 IPFS 上获得同等的情况呢？是的。所以我们试图使用完全相同的类比。因此 space 应用默认是加密的。ChainSafe 应用默认是加密的。所以基于网页的最终用户应用通常内置了加密功能。它们会在将数据放入网络之前对其进行加密。然后在应用设计环境中，你会想做同样的事情。这就像使用 AWS 一样，举个例子。如果你想让该数据保持私密，你会使用最先进的加密算法对其进行加密，然后将其放入网络中。
That makes sense. And then you kind of either, you have to kind of write that password down, or you could then use maybe a centralized service like OnePass or something like that to hold the passwords for you. But well, then, yeah, I guess you always need some kind of master password that you have kind of mentally. You can also, with a lot of these end user apps, you can also use a decentralized ID to log in. So I believe with some of these, you can log in with a MetaMask ID, which is just kind of an Ethereum wallet address, and that serves as your identification. Wow, man, I'm learning so much today, Michelle. This is awesome. So how do you get a decentralized ID? Oh, it's an Ethereum address. So MetaMask, Rainbow, a bunch of these are wallets. They both store, you know, kind of like your like nice leather
这就说得通了。然后你有点——要么你得把那个密码写下来，或者你也可以使用某种集中式服务，比如 OnePass 或类似的东西来为你保存密码。但是，然后，是的，我猜你总是需要在脑子里记住某种主密码。你还可以——通过许多这类终端用户应用，你还可以使用去中心化 ID 来登录。所以I believe 随着其中的一些应用，你可以使用 MetaMask ID 登录，这只是一种以太坊钱包地址，它可以充当你的身份识别。哇，天哪，我今天学到了好多，米歇尔。这太棒了。那么你如何获得一个去中心化 ID 呢？哦，它是一个以太坊地址。所以 MetaMask、Rainbow，这些都是钱包。它们既存储（你知道的）有点像你在日常生活中的那种漂亮的皮质
wallet in everyday life. It both acts as your identification, but it can also hold funds. Cool. Cool. Yeah. And so I guess the final question that was on my mind was just how do you keep bad content off IPFS? Yeah, really important because, you know, a lot of people have asked this question and we think about content moderation in a couple of layers. So at the protocol level, it's kind of like saying, hey, the inventor of JPEGs, like never wants bad child pornography to ever be stored in a JPEG ever again. It's kind of impossible to do that. So in at the format level, we don't want to, you know, control content, but at the services level, that's where, you know, if we're actively involved in providing a service, you know, we can and should have an opinion on what data we're going to be passing around. So through like Cloudflare runs an IPFS gateway, for example,
钱包。它既可以作为你的身份识别，也可以持有资金。酷。酷。是的。所以我想我脑海中的最后一个问题就是，你如何把不良内容挡在 IPFS 之外？是的，这真的很重要，因为（你知道的）很多人都问过这个问题，我们从几个层面来思考内容审核。所以在协议层面，这有点像在说，嘿，JPEG 的发明者——绝不希望任何坏的儿童色情内容再次被存储在 JPEG 中。要做到这一点是不可能的。所以在格式层面，我们不想（你知道的）控制内容，但在服务层面，那就是（你知道的）如果我们积极参与提供服务，（你知道的）我们可以也应该对我们要传递的数据持有看法。因此，通过像 Cloudflare 运行 IPFS 网关，举个例子，
and they'll sort of take down notices or, you know, add content to denialists if it's reported to be illegal. Similarly, Protocol Labs is IPFS gateway that we host, which is kind of that service between web two and web three. You can report abuse and have bad content taken down. And then there's also the decentralized option because everything we do, we kind of try to think, well, what is the most decentralized way to do it? The Filecoin protocol has a part where before you make a storage deal, you can ask the provider for some info about what they'll opt into or opt out of. And there's a team called Murmuration Labs building some content moderation capabilities into that where a storage provider can say, hey, I comply with GDPR. So that's like a feature I offer. If you choose to buy storage from me or another provider might say, hey, I'm located in Canada. And if the Canadian government mandates that you keep data
如果被举报为非法内容，他们会受理删除通知，或者（你知道的）将内容加入拒绝名单。同样，协议实验室（Protocol Labs）托管的 IPFS 网关——这是连接 Web 2 和 Web 3 的那种服务。你可以举报滥用行为并下架不良内容。然后还有去中心化的选项，因为我们所做的一切，我们都试着去思考，好吧，最去中心化的做法是什么？Filecoin 协议有一个部分，在进行存储交易之前，你可以向提供商询问一些关于他们选择加入或退出的信息。有一个名为 Murmuration Labs 的团队正在其中构建一些内容审核功能，存储提供商可以说，嘿，我符合 GDPR（通用数据保护条例）。所以这就像是我提供的一项功能。如果你选择从我这里购买存储空间，或者另一个提供商可能会说，嘿，位于加拿大的我，如果加拿大政府强制要求你将数据
physically in Canada, you can choose to buy data from me. So you're building those options into the protocol and allowing many parties to define what good content or bad content or what their storage policies are, is how we approach that. That makes sense. Super, super cool. If people want to get started with this, how would you recommend they kind of jump into this? A couple of really great resources for getting started. The first is a website called proto.school. And that's a series of interactive lessons and tutorials on the nuts and bolts of this technology. And then another really fun pathway is through hackathons. So you might have the impression that like in a hackathon, you get all crammed into a room for 48 hours and eat pizza and write code. Sounds awesome.
物理上保存在加拿大，你可以选择从我这里购买数据。所以将这些选项构建到协议中，并允许许多方来定义什么是好内容、什么是坏内容，或者什么是他们的存储政策，这就是我们处理这个问题的方式。这就说得通了。超级超级酷。如果人们想开始使用这个，你建议他们如何着手涉足其中？有几个非常棒的入门资源。第一个是一个叫做 proto.school 的网站。那是一系列关于这项技术核心要点的互动课程和教程。然后另一个非常有趣的途径是通过黑客松。所以你可能会有这样的印象，即在黑客松中，所有人被挤在一个房间里 48 小时，吃披萨并编写代码。听起来很棒。
Yeah, sounds awesome for some people. It's not everyone's privacy. But hackathons today have a much bigger emphasis on education. They often take place over several weeks. It's really about finding teams or community peers. Yeah, it can be even better. And because of COVID, I think there's, you know, people can access, many of these are virtual, so you can participate no matter where in the world you are. And so hackathons.filecoin.io is a website where people can learn about all the active hackathons that are happening now or coming up very soon. There's one called BuildQuest that we're running with ETH Global that's all about applying IPFS, Filecoin,
是的，对某些人来说听起来很棒。这并非所有人的菜。但今天的黑客松对教育有着更大的重视。它们通常历时数周。这真的关乎寻找团队或社区同伴。是的，甚至可能会更好。而且由于新冠疫情，我认为（你知道的）人们可以访问，其中许多是虚拟的，所以无论你身处世界何地都可以参与。因此 hackathons.filecoin.io 是一个网站，人们可以在上面了解当前正在进行或即将举行的所有活跃的黑客松。有一个叫 BuildQuest 的项目，我们正在与 ETH Global 一起运行，它全关于将 IPFS、Filecoin、
NFT storage, all these cool things to the development and design of games. Very cool. Yeah, I mean, that's also a great way to meet people who have kind of different levels of experience, different skill sets, and really network and form teams of people you can develop trust with. Yeah, absolutely. Nothing like going through the crucible of a project to really get to know people. And a lot of hackathon participants end up, we have a really awesome grants program, so people can apply for grants to continue the work that they started in a hackathon. There are job fairs, so sometimes people use their hackathon projects as sort of like portfolio showcases for showing that they're interested and capable of building in the decentralized web.
NFT 存储，所有这些很酷的东西应用到游戏的开发和设计中。非常酷。是的，我的意思是，这也是结识那些具有不同经验水平、不同技能组合的人，以及真正建立人脉并组建你可以与之建立信任的团队的好方法。是的，绝对的。没有什么比经历一个项目的严峻考验更能让人真正了解彼此了。而且许多黑客松参与者最终会——我们有一个非常棒的资助计划，所以人们可以申请资助来继续他们在黑客松中开始的工作。还有招聘会，所以有时人们将他们的黑客松项目用作某种作品集展示，以此表明他们有兴趣并且有能力在去中心化网络中进行构建。
Cool. What is the coolest project you've seen built on top of IPFS and Filecoin? Oh, there are so many. I think a really cool one is Audius, which is a decentralized music network that's really artist-friendly and takes advantage of community enthusiasm. So Audius is a series of, is a music distribution platform. It's alternative to things like Spotify and all of the music is stored, all the data stored in IPFS formats and a network of nodes serves it up.
酷。你见过的在 IPFS 和 Filecoin 之上构建的最酷的项目是什么？哦，有太多了。我认为一个非常酷的项目是 Audius，这是一个对艺术家非常友好并利用了社区热情的去中心化音乐网络。所以 Audius 是一系列——是一个音乐分发平台。它是诸如 Spotify 等平台的替代品，所有的音乐都存储着，所有的数据都存储在 IPFS 格式中，并由节点网络提供服务。
Wow. Super cool. So, so if, does it have the cataloging that Spotify has has like if i if i want to look up you know a certain type of music like if i want to play rock music or something in my browser will audius uh have something like that actually how do you spell audius audius is spelled a-u-d-i-u-s okay and the website is audius.co audius.co and you can yeah and you can explore music so there's different playlists uh there's some trending topics very very cool um i remember using uh this thing called gemendo which was you know totally web 2.0 but it was uh the cool thing about it was it was all um it was all music that was, I don't remember the terminology, but basically it was free to listen to.
哇。超级酷。所以，那么——它有 Spotify 那样的目录吗，就像如果我想查找（你知道的）某种特定类型的音乐，比如如果我想在我的浏览器中播放摇滚音乐或类似的东西，Audius 会有这样的内容吗？事实上，Audius 怎么拼？Audius 的拼写是 A-U-D-I-U-S。好的。网站是 audius.co，audius.co。并且你可以——是的，你可以探索音乐——有不同的播放列表，还有一些热门话题。非常非常酷。嗯，我记得我用过——这个叫做 Jamendo 的东西，（你知道的）完全是 Web 2.0，但它是——它很酷的一点在于，它全都是——全都是音乐，我不记得那个术语了，但基本上它是可以免费收听的。
But if you wanted to use it commercially, then you'd have to license it. But everyone who put their music on there were allowing individuals to listen to it for free. And it was just really liberating. I mean, you'd hear there's just a bit of everything, you know, it's like everyone could have a voice and there's actually a Canadian singer on there. It was really popular. He, he was like a parody or not, maybe not parodies wasn't parodying anything particular, but I'm trying to remember the name now, but, but he had a,
但如果你想进行商业使用，你就必须获得授权。不过所有把音乐放到上面的人都允许个人免费收听。而且这真的让人感到解放。我的意思是，你会听到各种各样的音乐，你知道的，就像每个人都可以发出自己的声音，而且上面实际上有一个加拿大歌手。非常受欢迎。他，他就像是一个恶搞或者不是，也许不是恶搞任何特定的东西，但我现在正努力记起名字，但是，但是他有一些
he had just some songs that had a really good beat to him. Yeah. And I think, you know, similar to the web, the music industry has seen a ton of consolidation where a few players have outsized power labels. Right. And in Audius, artists get 90 percent of revenue. Ten percent goes to the node operators that actually serve the music. And so up and coming artists can, you know, grow a following without having to, without having to like pass through the gatekeeping of a record label. Wow, that is super, super cool. Yeah, this is awesome.
歌曲节奏感真的很好。是的，而且我认为，（你知道的）类似于网络，音乐产业已经看到了大量的整合，少数几家巨头拥有过大的权力——唱片公司。没错。而在 Audius 中，艺术家获得 90% 的收入。10% 归实际提供音乐的节点运营者所有。因此，崭露头角的艺术家可以（你知道的）在不通过唱片公司把关的情况下建立粉丝群体。哇，这真的超级超级酷。是的，这太棒了。
And so folks out there, you know, check out, you know, these different links. You will post them in the show notes and, you know, try building something out there. I think it's really empowering. I think it's amazing. You could build something that can scale to extraordinary lengths
所以朋友们，（你知道的）去看看（你知道的）这些不同的链接。我们会在节目笔记中发布它们，并且（你知道的）尝试在那里构建一些东西。我认为这真的很赋能。我认为这太棒了。你可以构建一些能够扩展到非凡规模的东西，
without you getting hit with some massive AWS bill at the end of the day. And I think there's a lot of people paying attention to Web3, so it's a good place. We often talk about how the, you know, mobile app stores are just so saturated at this point. But this is, you know, an area that is still new. I mean, it could be really, you know, if you have a really cool idea, it's much more likely
而最终不会遭到巨额 AWS 账单的打击。而且我认为有很多人在关注 Web3，所以这是一个好地方。我们经常谈论（你知道的）移动应用商店在这一点上已经如此饱和。但这是一个（你知道的）依然崭新的领域。我的意思是，这可能真的（你知道的）如果你有一个非常酷的想法，当你在这个空间里时，人们更有可能看到它。
for people to see it when you're in this kind of space. Yeah. And I think, you know, I've experienced this twice, like working in Web3 now and also working in modernizing government tech. In a new space, there's room for it. You know, I think it's a great time for people to join because there's lots of problems to solve, lots of enthusiasm. If you're like a warm, smart body, you can definitely find a place to contribute your skills.
是的。而且我认为，（你知道的）我经历过两次这种情况，比如现在在 Web3 工作，以及在现代化政府科技中工作。在一个新的领域，有施展的空间。你知道的，我认为现在是人们加入的好时机，因为有很多问题需要解决，充满了热情。如果你是一个热情、聪明的人，你绝对可以找到一个能贡献你技能的地方。
Very cool. Is there like a Google for IPFS? You know, like how do people search for content? I mean, obviously, if you have the hashtag or the domain name, then you're set. But how do people get discovered when they're producing stuff that's decentralized? That's a great question. I don't think there's a single answer for that yet. But IPFS is often used in, there's a couple of projects like aiming to catalog all the data that's on IPFS. And then there's also, of course, like all the applications that are aiming to help people discover video or music or specific kinds of content that's stored on IPFS. Very cool. Very, very cool. So let's shift gears a little bit.
非常酷。有没有类似 IPFS 的谷歌？你知道的，人们如何搜索内容？我的意思是，显然，如果你有哈希值或者域名，那你就搞定了。但是当人们制作去中心化内容时，如何被别人发现呢？这是一个好问题。我认为目前还没有一个统一的答案。但 IPFS 通常被用于——有几个项目旨在编目 IPFS 上的所有数据。然后当然还有（你知道的）所有旨在帮助人们发现存储在 IPFS 上的视频、音乐或特定类型内容的应用。非常酷。非常，非常酷。所以让我们稍微转换一下话题。
And why don't you tell us about Protocol Labs, the company? So we know Protocol Labs. Actually, wait, let's move back up a little bit. So what's the relationship between Protocol Labs and IPFS? Do Protocol Labs invent IPFS, or are they sort of caretakers? How does that work? Yeah, both. So Protocol Labs is dedicated to the research, development, and deployment of new web technologies. And IPFS was one of the first projects out of there. LibP2P is another one, Filecoin. But we actually work now with a number of communities
你为什么不给我们讲讲协议实验室（Protocol Labs）这家公司呢？所以我们知道协议实验室。事实上，等等，让我们稍微回溯一下。那么协议实验室和 IPFS 之间的关系是什么？是协议实验室发明了 IPFS，还是他们算是维护者？那是怎么运作的？是的，两者都是。所以协议实验室致力于新网络技术的研发和部署。而 IPFS 是其中的首批项目之一。LibP2P 是另一个，还有 Filecoin。但我们现在实际上与
and teams all across the web that are not necessarily part of Protocol Labs itself. And that's what makes IPFS and Filecoin and all these technologies even better. Ah, got it. That makes sense. And so for folks who are super interested in this and want to join Protocol Labs, do you have internships or full-time positions? And what are the logistics there? Are you hiring for a particular city?
网络各处的许多社区和团队合作，它们不一定属于协议实验室本身。而这正是让 IPFS、Filecoin 以及所有这些技术变得更加出色的原因。啊，明白了。这就说得通了。因此，对于对这个超级感兴趣并想加入协议实验室的人来说，你们有实习或全职职位吗？那里的后勤情况是怎样的？你们是在某个特定城市招聘吗？
Is it a distributed company or lab? How does that work? We're 100% remote. And the founder actually met the first couple employees on IRC. So don't have an office at all. Pre-COVID, we'd get together pretty often in person. And pending safety measures is starting to come back now but we kind of do a lot of work asynchronously through discord or slack github and then we use video just for as a supplement to that so it's remote
这是一个分布式公司或实验室吗？那是怎么运作的？我们是 100% 远程办公的。创始人实际上是在 IRC 上认识前几名员工的。所以根本没有办公室。在新冠疫情之前，我们会经常聚在一起进行线下交流。随着安全措施的落实，现在又开始恢复了，但我们大部分工作是通过 Discord、Slack、GitHub 异步进行的，然后我们使用视频作为补充，所以这是一个
first company where I think we have people in over a dozen countries all around the world many different time zones and we're hiring at all levels. So protocol.ai slash join is the website where you can find out about different roles. And we've actually introduced a new program called Launchpad. It's sort of like an apprenticeship or training program for people interested in joining,
远程优先的公司，我认为我们在全球十几个国家拥有员工，跨越许多不同的时区，并且我们在各个级别都在招聘。所以 protocol.ai/slash/join 是你可以了解不同职位的网站。我们实际上推出了一个名为 Launchpad 的新项目。这有点像为有兴趣加入、
learning really quickly, and then getting matched to a number of different projects. So that is dedicated to early career folks or people transitioning from Web 2 to Web 3. So for those roles, we're not expecting prior knowledge, just, you know, smart, fast learners, awesome people bringing other skills to the table. And then we teach web three development skills in a one month sort of accelerated program. Wow, that is really, really fascinating. Very, very cool. So folks, what is a way for someone to what is the ideal resume for you? And what's a way that someone out there can, you know, what's your advice for folks who want to get into these programs?
快速学习并随后被匹配到许多不同项目的人准备的学徒期或培训项目。所以这是专门为职业早期的人或者从 Web 2 过渡到 Web 3 的人准备的。对于这些角色，我们不期望有先验知识，只需要（你知道的）聪明、学习速度快、有着其他技能的优秀人才。然后我们在一个月的加速计划中教授 Web3 开发技能。哇，这真的非常非常迷人。非常，非常酷。所以各位，什么样的人对你们来说是理想的简历？对于想要进入这些项目的人，你们有什么建议？
That is a really great question. What's an ideal resume? So across the board, we're hiring in lots of different roles that, you know, entry level all the way through senior and principal level. So the expectations are different. But I think some things are consistent across the board. One is really great ability to work in the open, to navigate the ambiguity
这是一个非常好的问题。什么是理想的简历？总的来说，我们在招募各种不同的职位，（你知道的）从入门级一直到高级和资深级别。所以期望是不同的。但我认为有些事情在各个层面上是一致的。一个是真正出色的在公开透明中工作的能力，能够驾驭模糊性——
of like having your design decisions happen on GitHub where everyone can see, being able to synthesize ideas and writing really well and communicate and collaborate in the open is a big one. And then also to bring other people along with you. So not just to be the smartest person in the room, but communicate it in a way that influences the community. Because especially in some of the projects that have fully decentralized governance structures, like you can't dictate change. So I mean, this is true of working on open
比如让你的设计决策发生在每个人都能看到的 GitHub 上，能够很好地综合想法并进行写作，以及在公开场合进行沟通和协作，这是一个大项。然后还要能够带上其他人一起前进。所以不仅要做房间里最聪明的人，还要以能够影响社区的方式进行沟通。因为特别是在一些具有完全去中心化治理结构的项目中，（你知道的）你无法强令变革。所以——我的意思是，这对于在世界各地参与
large scale open source software around the world, you know, no matter what project or company it is, is the ability to influence with or without authority. Cool, that totally makes sense. I remember, I still feel sometimes like, you know, when I'm using GitHub on some open source projects, especially ones that are more popular, you know, I'll get an email, someone has a question, I'll kind of shoot off a reply, like, no, it won't work or something, you know, I'm just kind of like on another reply or something. It actually is kind of intimidating. You kind of realize, people can... You really open yourselves up when you do something out there on the web, on the public GitHub and all of that.
大规模开源软件工作的人来说是真的，无论是什么项目或公司，这就是带有或不带有权威去产生影响的能力。酷，这完全说得通。我记得，我有时仍然觉得，（你知道的）当我在某些开源项目上使用 GitHub 时，尤其是那些更受欢迎的项目，（你知道的）我会收到一封电子邮件，有人问了一个问题，我会随手回复一句，比如，不，那样行不通，或者类似的话，（你知道的）我只是在进行另一次回复或者别的什么。这实际上有点吓人。你会意识到，人们可以……当你把事情放到网络上、公开的 GitHub 以及所有这些地方时，你真的把自己敞开了。
But I think that it also is really humanizing. It's like sometimes people are in a hurry, sometimes they're not. Sometimes I can write really long replies trying to give people insight. And, and so, um, you know, I think, you know, getting kind of in touch with your sort of humanity or like realizing that they're all real people under the hood is really cool. I remember before, uh, I went to the Valley, some of these people were, um, just like, I didn't know if they were real people or not. You know, like you hear like stories of like, Oh, Jeff Dean, you know,
但我认为这也非常有人情味。这就像有时人们很匆忙，有时则不然。有时我可以写出非常长的回复，试图给人们提供见解。因此，（你知道的）我认为（你知道的）重新接触你的人性，或者意识到在底层他们都是真实的人，这真的很酷。我记得在——我来到硅谷之前，其中一些人——
like he writes everything in machine code and he has like all these like, you know, kind of these people are sort of luminaries. And they find out at the end of the day, they're just they're normal people and you can email them. And most of them are super polite and super outgoing, willing to help, which is really cool. Yeah, I think there's kind of this like uncanny valley, right? I think like new people and then the super experienced, like the best people are the most welcoming. And sometimes there's like a little bit of gatekeeping in the middle, but we don't need that. Right. And so I think that's, you know, that's something that we look for in folks. Another is, especially if people are coming new to the Web3 space is just like, just try it out, you know, come to the interview or come to the conversation, having tried to run a node or you know build something with some of the
就像我不知道他们是真人还是别的什么。你知道的，就像你听到类似的故事，哦，杰夫·迪恩（Jeff Dean），（你知道的）他用机器代码编写所有东西，而且他有所有这些（你知道的）类似的大牛。结果到头来，他们只是普通人，你可以给他们发电子邮件。而且他们大多数人都超级礼貌、超级外向、乐于助人，这真的很酷。是的，我认为存在这种所谓的“恐怖谷效应”，对吧？我认为像新人然后是超级有经验的人——最好的人最热情。有时中间会有一点把关，但我们不需要那个。没错。所以我想这就是（你知道的）我们在人们身上寻找的东西。另一个是，特别是如果人们是 Web3 空间的新人，那就是——去尝试一下，带着曾经尝试运行过节点的心态来面试或谈话，或者（你知道的）用我们提供的工具构建一些东西，或者关注一些教程，以便你获得的（你知道的）不仅仅是表面上的好奇心和兴趣，而是真正理解——是什么让 IPFS、Filecoin 或者是 Web3 整体——（你知道的）在激励着你；所以我们不（你知道的）许多职位不需要先验知识，但它们确实需要真正的兴趣。酷。这就说得通了。所以，是的，正如我们之前讨论过的，如果你在外面（你知道的）想要获取一个网站或网络服务，或者（你知道的）某种类型的东西，它可能是一组你想备份的文件。你现在可以使用这些技术免费或几乎免费地完成所有这些。
tools we have available or follow some tutorials so that you get you know not just a surface level curiosity and interest but really understand like what is it about ipfs or filecoin that or web3 in general that that that um that is motivating to you um so we don't you know many of the roles don't require prior knowledge, but they do require like a genuine interest. Cool. And that makes sense. So, so yeah, as we talked about earlier, you know, if you out there, you know, want to get a website or a web service or, you know, some type of thing out there, you know, it could be a set of files that you want to keep a backup of. You can do all of that right now for free or mostly for free using these technologies.
所以我可以说，对于想要成为协议实验室或更广泛努力的一部分的人来说，去构建东西吧。你就可以成为其中的一部分。它是非常容易接近的。我们在 docs.ipfs.io 或 nftschool.dev 上有大量的教程。如果你想开始使用这些或者跳进我们的 IPFS Discord，你可以通过在网上搜索找到它。有很多人随时准备帮助你。非常酷。所以，（你知道的）我们以你说你想成为一名建筑师开始了这个话题。所以，（你知道的）我们有点回到了原点。我觉得你正在参与构建下一版本的网络架构。这让你感觉
And so I would say for folks who want to be a part of Protocol Labs or this effort more broadly, just build stuff. And just you can be a part of it. It's very accessible. We have tons of tutorials on docs.ipfs.io or nftschool.dev. And if you want to get started with those or hop in our IPFS discord, you can find that by searching the web. Lots of people ready to help you out. Very cool. So, you know, we started this with you saying you wanted to be an architect. And so, you know, we've kind of come full circle. I feel like you're part of architecting the next version of the web. And what is, how does that
如何？这真的很有趣。真的很好玩。我也开始意识到，网络上的东西比它理应存在的时间更长。Google Forms 十多年前就推出了，它虽然进行了一些演变，但并没有被取代。所以我认为这也有一种真正的管家精神或责任感，即我们在构建正确的构件，构建正确的文化，为未来的网络创造一个真正健康的未来。这真的非常非常酷。好吧，我们绝对会发布所有这些链接。
make you feel? It's really interesting. It's really fun. I've also come to realize that stuff on the web lasts longer than it's supposed to. Google Forms was launched over a decade ago and it's evolved a little bit, but it hasn't replaced. So I think there's also a real stewardship or responsibility sense that we're building the right building blocks, building the right culture to create a really healthy web into the future. That is very, very cool. Well, we will definitely post all of these links.
我真的鼓励大家，我们收到了太多人的电子邮件，问我如何进入这个行业，进入任何这些行业，更广泛地说，进入软件行业？我们的回答始终是构建东西。但我认为正如许多人所指出的那样，像应用商店或 Web 2.0 已经非常饱和了。所以你可以构建东西并把它展示给你的朋友。
I really encourage folks out there. We get so many emails from people saying, how do I get into the industry, into any of these industries, software more broadly? And our answer has consistently been to build things. But I think as a lot of folks have pointed out, things like the App Store or Web 2.0 are just very saturated. And so you can build stuff and show it to your friends.
如今，让你的应用挤进应用商店的排行榜前列是非常困难的。所以这是下一个前沿领域。我认为这是一个有很多人在关注的地方。而且还没有那么多大玩家。我的意思是，它不像应用商店那样饱和，让你无法获得关注。所以为 Web 3.0 构建东西吧。
It's very hard to make it to the top of the App Store with your app nowadays. And so this is sort of the next frontier. I think that this is a place that has a lot of people putting their eyeballs on it. And there aren't that many big players yet. I mean, it's not as saturated as the App Store where you can't really get noticed. So build stuff for Web 3.0.
如今，让你的应用程序登上应用商店的顶峰非常困难。所以这可以说是下一个前沿领域。我认为这是一个吸引了大量目光的地方。而且现在还没有那么多大玩家。我的意思是，它不像应用商店那样饱和，让你根本无法引人注目。所以，为Web 3.0开发产品吧。
And as always, if you build anything or when you build things, at us on Twitter, we love to see all the stuff that folks have been building and learning. Definitely keep doing that. If people want to reach, you know, Protocol AI or reach you, Michelle, or, you know, ask questions, where would be a good place for them to do that? Two places. One is the IPFS Discord. I'm mosh1812 on there. And the other is I'm mishmosh on Twitter. Oh, very cool. Is that mosh after the terminal emulator? It does not come from the terminal emulator, although that's a fun coincidence. I think it
和往常一样，如果你构建了什么或者在构建什么，在推特上@我们，我们很喜欢看大家一直在构建和学习的所有东西。一定要继续保持。如果人们想要联系，你知道，Protocol AI，或者联系你，Michelle，或者，你知道，问问题，去哪里比较好呢？两个地方。一个是 IPFS Discord。我在那里是 mosh1812。另一个是我的推特 mishmosh。哦，太酷了。那个 mosh 是指终端模拟器吗？它不是来自终端模拟器，尽管这是一个有趣的巧合。我想它
just evolved out of my name, Michelle. Oh, very cool. Well, thank you so much, Michelle, for coming on the show. I personally learned a ton. Patrick, I'm sure, learned a ton. Both of us are super interested in this. I see it pop up on the news and on Hacker News and on LinkedIn all the time. And I'm really fascinated. And I think you really shed a light on all of this different technology. And we're able to really dive in light on all of this different technology. And we're able to really dive in on how it works under the hood. We talked to everything from hashing to pinning content. Really, really fascinating stuff.
只是从我的名字 Michelle 演变而来的。哦，非常酷。好的，非常感谢 Michelle 来到我们的节目。我个人学到了很多。帕特里克肯定也学到了很多。我们俩对这个都超级感兴趣。我经常在新闻、Hacker News 和领英上看到它弹出来。我真的非常着迷。而且我认为你确实让我们对所有这些不同的技术有了清晰的认识。我们能够真正深入了解所有这些不同的技术。我们能够真正深入了解它是如何在底层工作的。我们讨论了从哈希到固定内容的一切。真的非常有趣的东西。
We have a bunch of links in the show notes. So folks out there, just go to www.programmingthrowdown.com or maybe go to our IPFS site. I'll have to see if I can build something there. But for now, I'll have to go to our Web 2.0 site and check out our show notes. Michelle, thank you so much for coming on the show. I really, really appreciate it. Thanks for having me, Jason and Patrick. Great to be here and hope to see everyone on the decentralized Web. Cool. All right, everyone. Thanks again for supporting us on patreon and uh and uh through audible um i hope everyone has an amazing couple of weeks and we'll see you all on the next episode bye music by eric barnmeller programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attribution share alike 2.0 license you're free to share copy distribute transmit the work to remix adapt the
我们在节目文稿中有大量的链接。所以各位，只需访问 www.programmingthrowdown.com，或者去我们的 IPFS 网站。我得看看我能不能在那里建个东西。但现在，我得去我们的 Web 2.0 网站查看我们的节目文稿。Michelle，非常感谢你来到节目中。我真的非常非常感激。谢谢邀请我，Jason 和 Patrick。很高兴来到这里，并希望在去中心化的网络上见到大家。酷。好的，各位。再次感谢大家在 Patreon 上对我们的支持，以及通过 Audible，希望大家度过美好的一两周，我们将在下一期节目中见到大家，再见，音乐由 Eric Barnmeller 提供，Programming Down 下发基于知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 协议。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行混编、改编作品，
work but you must provide an attribution uh to uh patrick and i and uh share alike in kind There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但你必须注明我和帕特里克的署名，并以相同方式共享。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。